[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALCOLM REYNOLDS:
My name is Malcolm
and I'm a research
engineer at DeepMind.
TAMARA NORMAN: Hi,
my name is Tamara
and I'm a software
engineer at DeepMind.
MALCOLM REYNOLDS: So we're
here today to talk about Sonnet
and hopefully answer
some questions for you,
so what is Sonnet, why
DeepMind has found it useful,
and why it might
be useful to you,
and then talk a
bit about our plans
for the future of the library.
So Sonnet is DeepMind's
library for constructing
neural networks in TensorFlow.
We've been working
on it since 2016
and it's been in open source
for the last couple of years.
And you can try the TensorFlow
1.0 version with this command
line here.
But you might be thinking,
sounds interesting.
Why does this exist?
And that is a very
legitimate question.
So to answer that, we
have to take a little trip
down memory lane.
So 2014, TensorFlow is
in development at Brain,
but there's no
open-source release yet.
And unrelatedly I guess,
DeepMind is acquired by Google.
So a little bit of
code archeology here.
So does anybody recognize what
system this is written in?
Hands up if it looks
vaguely familiar.
OK, not too many hands.
So I censored some of this just
to make it slightly harder.
So now it may be clearer
that this is actually
Torch7 code, or Lua Torch.
And specifically, we're
defining a module here.
That's what the red
arrow is pointing to.
So DeepMind was an
entirely Torch7 operation,
at least in the research
side when I joined.
And it's a really great
piece of software.
If you're interested in the
sort of history of deep learning
abstractions, you know,
the abstractions in Torch
really go back to stuff
from the '90s, like Lush.
So fast forward a
few years, we have
dozens of research projects
going on, hundreds of people
involved, and being able to
kind of quickly share code
between the projects
was really critical.
So somebody comes
up with a new RNN,
everyone else can try
that out with minimal fuss
and no changing of the code.
And we thought we had
a pretty good workflow
and we were pretty
happy with it,
and then we decided
to just get rid of it
all and start from scratch.
Seems questionable.
But the reason is we were
transitioning to TensorFlow.
And obviously, there's
many great reasons
to use TensorFlow.
We've been hearing about
them for the last few days.
Top of the list for us
was better alignment
and collaboration with
our colleagues at Google.
It was designed for distributed
training from day one, which
Torch really wasn't, and
that was becoming a problem
in some of our research.
And we wanted to really take
the best advantage of TPUs,
and obviously, TensorFlow
is the best way to use them.
And we knew from
initial assessments
this was going to be
flexible enough to build
whatever we need on top of.
But we weren't actually
starting from scratch.
We had some stuff we
really wanted to preserve.
And it's not that we want
the same APIs as Lua Torch.
That would not have
been the right decision.
But we wanted the same
engineering philosophy.
So what we mean by this
is like hopefully we're
going to state
through this talk.
So first of all,
kind of composable
modules using
object-oriented programming.
Now it's definitely
totally valid
to have a kind of purely
functional library.
But we found that when you start
having lots of variable reuse
RNNs, those kind of
features, objects really
made a lot more sense.
So we definitely
want to keep that.
We wanted to decouple
the model definition
from how it's actually trained.
And this is really key,
and I will comment on this
again shortly.
Hackability is really crucial.
We don't think we can anticipate
everything our research
scientists might want, like
years or even months ahead
of time.
But what we can do is
have code that they
are able to dig down,
hopefully not too far,
make the changes they need to,
maybe by forking the module,
and we're kind of
comfortable with that,
and then continue
with their research.
And it's important to
emphasize we're really
optimizing for research.
You've heard a lot about
a lot of great solutions
for kind of moving
things into production.
And that's really important,
but for DeepMind research, that
really happens very rarely.
So we prefer to
optimize the libraries
based on research progress,
next paper, that kind of thing.
And overall, we're looking
for a standard interface
with really minimal assumptions
that doesn't prevent you
from doing anything.
So composability.
What do I mean by this?
Hopefully, anyone who's
used an LSTM would be like,
yes, you can implement this
out of some Linear modules,
and they contain the
variables and LSTM
is a thing around all of that.
But you can go many
levels up from there.
So the differentiable
neural computer,
which was the first project
I worked on at DeepMind,
you know, that's a
module that contains
an LSTM plus some other stuff.
And we worked on that
and got the paper out,
and then the code
is sitting there,
and then another team could
come along and be like, hey,
we have some system
which requires an RNN.
It's currently an
LSTM, but maybe we'll
just try this instead.
And you know, it's been
used in many places,
but I think the most significant
maybe was the Capture the Flag
work, which had some really
cool results, specifically
with the DNC controller.
And you know, if they
could reuse the code,
like they didn't need to
ask us about how it worked.
They didn't even need
to read the code.
They're just like, this is an
RNN that conforms to some API,
we'll just drop it
in, and it works.
Orthogonality to the
training setup dimension.
So I did a quick survey.
We have roughly two setups
for unsupervised learning,
four for reinforcement
learning, and many more setups
for single projects.
And to be clear,
what I mean here,
this is kind of everything
that goes on above the model.
Like how do you
feed it the data,
how do you launch experiments,
monitor them, like
what configurability is
there for the researchers.
All this kind of
stuff is what I'm
referring to as training setup.
And this might seem
like a ton of, you know,
repeated effort and
duplicated code,
but we don't actually
view this as a problem.
These different setups exist
for different research goals.
And trying to push everything
into a single training setup,
even just for RL,
it's been tried.
We don't think it works.
So we're kind of happy with
lots of different setups
which kind of coexist.
And the reason
it's not a problem,
apart from the serving
different research goals,
is that we can reuse Sonnet
modules between all of them.
And that means we're not like
redoing the DNC from scratch.
So I've talked a bunch about
what we've already done
with Sonnet and TensorFlow 1.
Tamara is going to talk
a bit about the future.
TAMARA NORMAN: So yeah.
Cheers, Malcolm.
So what will Sonnet
look like in TF 2?
DeepMind are really
excited for TF 2,
and are planning
once again to invest
and changing our workflow
in adopting TF 2.
Eager execution has already been
widely tried by researchers,
and they really enjoy
the improved flexibility,
debugging, and simplicity
that come from this.
And they're looking
forward to the benefits
of this being part of TF 2.
But one thing we've noticed
is that Sonnet 1 was
based on features, like
variable scripts quite heavily,
and these are going away.
This isn't something
that we're worried about.
We're really excited
and follow TF
into this much more
natural and Pythonic world.
So how do we plan on making
Sonnet in this new world?
So we've built tf.Module
as the base of Sonnet 2.
This is a stateful container,
which provides both variable
and model tracking.
It's been designed by
engineers at DeepMind
in collaboration between
many individuals at DeepMind
and Brain, learning lessons from
both Sonnet 1 and Lua Torch.
It's now been upstreamed
into TensorFlow.
And you can try it
out in the alpha
that's been released over
the course of Dev Summit.
It will soon form the
basis of many higher level
components in TF, including
things like TF Keras.
So what about modules?
Modules can have
multiple forward methods,
addressing a limitation that
we found within Sonnet 1.
They can be nested
arbitrarily, allowing
for the creation
of complex models,
like the [INAUDIBLE] that
was talked about earlier.
And they have automatic
name scoping, which
allows for easy debugging.
So what are we trying
to do with Sonnet 2?
We're aiming to
create a library which
makes very few assumptions
about what users want to do,
both with their networks
and their training loops.
It's been designed in close
collaboration with researchers.
And we think it's a lightweight,
simple abstraction that's
as close to the
maths as it can be.
So what the features of Sonnet?
Sonnet has the ability to
have multiple forward methods,
something enabled by tf.Module.
But what does that really mean?
There will be an easy way to
create [? excessive ?] methods
on an object that
can have access
to the same state and variables.
An example of where
this is useful
will be in a few slides time.
One thing that we've
found that's really
crucial with Sonnet 1 is that
it's really easy to compose it
with other systems.
Sonnet 1 works out of
the box with Replicator,
which is our internal solution
to distributed training,
even though these libraries
were never designed
with each other in mind.
They don't even have a
dependency on each other.
They both just use
TensorFlow under the hood.
It's up to users
to define how they
want to compose their system
together and decide where they
want to put things
like that [INAUDIBLE]
to ensure that the gradients
are the same across all
the devices.
We plan for the same philosophy
to be implemented in Sonnet 2.
Replicator has been merged
with Distribution Strategy,
so you'll all be
able to try this out.
And you can find more details on
Replicator on the DeepMind blog
post.
So what do we want
to do within Sonnet?
We also want to continue
to provide the flexibility
and composability
that we've already
heard about that they have in
v1, such as things that models
can be composed
in arbitrary ways,
and that no training
loop is provided.
We still don't want
to aim to predict
where the research will go.
So what does the code look like?
This is the linear layer.
It's pretty much the
implementation, just
without some of the comments.
And one thing we've
been really excited by
is how simple an
implementation we've
been able to create on top
of tf.Module and TF 2 is.
Research is by nature
about pushing boundaries.
And we think these simple
layers with minimal boilerplate
will encourage forking and
inheritance as a way of trying
out variations.
Another thing I just
wanted to highlight
is that modules don't
necessarily have to be layers
or even have state.
They just inherit from tf.Module
and get the name scoping
from that.
In Sonnet, we also implement
optimizers of modules.
They are simply nodes
on a graph and benefit
with the name scoping from
tf.Module, which greatly adds
to the visualization
of graphs and debugging
of operations later on.
The forward method on optimizers
isn't even [INAUDIBLE]..
It's the supply update, which
doesn't return anything.
It just takes your
gradients and your variables
and applies them together.
And as promised,
here's the example
of using multiple
forward methods.
Making something like a
variation [INAUDIBLE] encoder
or encapsulate both an
encoder and a decoder,
so they can be trained
together whilst exposing both
the forward methods on them
both as a way for testing
and using them later on.
So what have we found when
implementing Sonnet in TF 2?
We've been doing
it for a while now,
and we found that we've
had a much simpler, more
understandable code than before.
The debugging has been vastly
improved and less painful
with Eager mode.
And we have initially seen
some significant speed ups
with TF function.
I think this will be a hugely
powerful tool going forwards.
So when can you try this out?
The road map for
Sonnet 2 is on the way.
It's on the way.
tf.Module is already
available in the alpha release
in TF Core.
We're iterating currently
on basic modules
now with researchers with the
alpha release on GitHub soon.
And hopefully, we'll have a beta
release sometime in the summer.
And now over to Malcolm.
He's going to talk
to you about some
of the projects, some of
which you may have heard of,
which have used and been
enabled by features of Sonnet 1
that we're taking
forward into Sonnet 2.
MALCOLM REYNOLDS:
Thanks, Tamara.
So just a few samples
of stuff that's
been done over
the past few years
in Sonnet and TensorFlow 1.
So this is the
generative query network.
So it's kind of receiving,
like, 2D rendering observations
at the top.
And then it's able to infer
what the 3D environment looks
like and put the camera
in any new position.
And you can see here the
different probabilistic views
of what the whole
environment could look like.
And this is, like,
a classic example
of several papers
worth of research,
which are all like
modules, which then
get kind of built on top of.
So the original paper was draw
back in the Lua Torch days.
And then we expanded on
that with convolutional draw
and then the generative
query network.
AlphaStar, something
quite recent.
And Sonnet was really
key here because there's
no assumptions on the
shape of what's coming
in and out of each module.
Both the observations
and actions
for the StarCraft environment
are extremely complex
hierarchical structures.
The action space,
you need to have
a kind of autoregressive
model to pick
whether you're
going to move a unit
and then where you're
going to move the unit to.
And the fact that
Sonnet had been
built with minimal assumptions
about what goes in and out
meant that this was
actually quite easy.
Another interesting aspect here
is how the model is actually
trained.
So, the details are on a blog
post on the DeepMind website.
But the AlphaStar League is
quite a complicated set up
with lots of different agents.
And they train against
frozen versions of themselves
from the past and try and
learn to exploit them.
And then you make
a new agent that
tries to learn to exploit
all the previous ones.
And this kind of custom setup is
a good reason why we don't just
try and stick with one
training style for everything,
because even a year ago, I don't
think we could have anticipated
what kind of elaborate
training scheme
would have been necessary
to make this work.
And finally, BigGAN.
I suspect a lot of people
are quite familiar with this.
But just in case
you're not, this
is not a real dog,
not a real photo.
This is randomly generated.
And I think the key
aspects of Sonnet
here was that the underlying
GAN architecture was, like,
maybe relatively similar
to things that had already
been in the literature.
There was a few key
components which
made it really a lot better.
One of them was being able to
train it on an entire [? TPE ?]
pod.
And a key aspect here was
cross replica [INAUDIBLE]..
So the researchers
involved could just say,
here's a normal GAN made
out of normal modules.
We need to, like,
hack the batch norm,
like, completely
replace it to do kind
of interesting [? TPE ?] stuff.
And then everything
else is just kind of--
just works as normal.
And obviously, we
can't talk about BigGAN
without briefly having
a look at dogball.
So here's a little a of dogball.
And then, that's
probably enough.
So in conclusion,
Sonnet is a library
that's been designed in
collaboration with DeepMind
research scientists.
We've been using it very
happily for the last few years.
We're looking forward to using
it in the TensorFlow 2 version.
It works for us and
it might work for you.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]